and that is why the republicans are
scared this morning
they're terrified
that this leaked
i'm talking about the supreme court
decision to overturn roe v wade and
strip away the liberty and the rights of
women all over this country don't think
they won't come after the 19th amendment
either
they're ready they're they're gonna
fight
they're gonna fight
yes it's a constitutional amendment and
some say oh tony tony they'll never take
that constitutional amendment away
they'll never take the the right of
women to vote away oh really
they won't huh they won't try to chip
away
at women's liberty
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
that's what you think
that they're not willing to chip away at
a woman's liberty in this country and
her rights
well good luck with that narrative from
here on out
i've been saying yelling and screaming
for months and months and months that
these fascists are coming for you
and it won't stop it won't stop
at women's right to the autonomy of
their body it will not stop there it
won't stop in the red states in the
cheeto dust confederacy it won't stop
there
they will not quit
they will not in the scourge of fascism
around this country to turn our entire
country not just the red states not just
where they have control
their goal
is for a fascist authoritarian state
to tell you what you
can and cannot do with your body
to tell you what you can and cannot
consent for your body your children and
your family
they're ready folks
they picked the hill to die on that's
where they want to fight are we going to
stand down in the valley
and yell at at them to say come down
here come down here and fight us where
we want to fight no we march up on the
hill and we fight the battle that they
want to fight they want to take your
[ __ ] liberty away from you
now is the time now
is the time
to fight
so don't just tweet
get on your feet
march
protest
yell scream
be divisive that's right tony don't say
be divisive oh really
oh really
you're just gonna you're just gonna
you're just gonna let fascism take over
the country
because you're unwilling
you're unwilling to call fascism fascism
they're they're concerned about the leak
this morning oh my god can you imagine
who leaked this information
so early
that women in this country would
organize and march against us that's
what they're [ __ ] worried about folks
they're worried now more than ever
that the mobilization
a pro-democracy people in this country
has a head start
on the decision of the supreme court to
take away your
liberty
and all you men out there they're
listening to me thinking oh well what
the hell's this got to do with me hell i
can't have an abortion you think they're
not coming for you
they're ready to turn this into an
authoritarian fascist state they've been
ready for a long
[ __ ] time
a long [ __ ] time
they've been ready to turn this into an
authoritarian fascist state
it is very clear in this country what we
must do
we must participate in democracy five
thousand percent
you know what scares these fascists more
than anything in the world
not guns not threats
democracy
terrifies them
the will of the people
frightens the holy [ __ ]
out of them
so let's use that weapon
let's use democracy let's show them
what we the people can do
when we exercise our right to our
democracy
and i'll write to our liberty and if you
today are not standing up just [ __ ]
furious
that these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
that were bought and paid for for our
supreme court are stripping away our
citizens and our women in this country's
liberty you
are a piece of [ __ ] garbage and you
are not for democracy
i don't give a [ __ ] about pro-life and
pro-choice partial bursts abortion i
don't give a
[ __ ]
at this point
this is only about one fight and one
fight only
are you going to let them come and take
your rights
because they're coming
they're coming for the 19th amendment
you don't think that you think they're
just gonna stand back and take women's
liberty and then let them vote
to secure it to codify it no they will
do anything in their power anything even
try to commit a coup
on our democracy
overturn our vote overthrow our
constitution
they're willing to do anything and
everything and they will take help from
anyone
including other authoritarians like
vladimir putin
and the scourge of disinformation and
misinformation and lies you lying
[ __ ]
and they've been doing it for decades
it ain't just now this lie about partial
burst abortion get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] that's all a [ __ ] lie
the lies that they spread on social
media of pictures of babies being killed
you're a [ __ ] liar
it's lies
and if you're pro-democracy out there if
you want to stand
for the vote for the people for women
for children all around this country and
to save lives now
is the time to get engaged
for our democracy
engage in the ballot
because they're coming for it
they're coming for the ballot your
ballot they're coming for it
mark my words doubt me
oh tony they'll never overturn roe v
wade you can't overturn roe v wade oh
well susan collins says oh well i'm
reassured that brett kavanaugh
and amy comey barrett and neil gorsuch
will not overturn roe v wade
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you're going to trust susan collins
if susan collins came out today and said
oh there's no way there's no way that
republicans that the gqp that the
fascist the nazi party that they are the
despicable ninja poot nazis
there's no way they'll try to try to
bang up the woman's vote try to prevent
women
and feminists everywhere from voting
bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
hide and watch
hide
and
watch
or
or
you can get on your feet
and you can go engage in the ballot
and enough of this [ __ ] it's his
fault it's her fault it's his fault and
hits shut the [ __ ] up
it's enough blaming ourselves
now is the time to not press blame now
is the time to fight who gives a [ __ ]
whose fault this is
who gives a good god damn who did what
and who said what and who when and who
where get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
more of that is gonna cause
more of fascism that's right you're you
stand around pointing fingers at whose
fault this is and you don't go up on
that hill and you fight for that ballot
you will lose you will [ __ ] lose and
everyone out there listening to my voice
continually says over and over and over
again democrats don't have a message
they never have a message they can't get
on message they can't find a message
they can't message worth of [ __ ]
it ain't up to the politicians folks
the pro-lifers the people that want to
strip away women's liberty the
anti-woman party
that is the gqp
they're organized folks
they're [ __ ] organized and they're
ready to whip your ass and take your
rights and make this a fascist state
they're ready they're not just gonna
stop at the [ __ ] red states they're
not just gonna go oh well texas and
florida and kentucky you know missouri
at there's no abortion clinics there so
now we're done we're over we're good
we're good to go no
they're coming
they're coming for the blue states
they're going to do everything they can
to take away safe medical procedures for
women
because they [ __ ] hate women making
choices about their bodies
especially when it comes to
stockpiling their country full of
low-income workers
that's right
you think it matters you think they give
a [ __ ] about life
you think they give two [ __ ] shits
about children these are the same
[ __ ] that are sexualizing your
children's gender with legislation
they're trying to marry children with
legislation in states
they were locking children up in cages
at the border you think they give a [ __ ]
about human life and children get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
now is the time
now
yesterday two weeks ago a month ago
they have awakened
a sleeping giant
and my message to them to the fascists
in this country you
have no idea what the [ __ ] woke is you
sons of [ __ ]
you have no [ __ ] clue
so i implore you fight fight fight fight
fight
democracy is worth every single little
inch
so go on that hill and fight for liberty
with the ballot use the ballot use
democracy against them
they fear it the most that's why that's
why you see
you see marsha blackburn this morning
we didn't find who leaked this they're
all they're highly concerned with who
leaked it
they don't give a good goddamn
about the liberty that is about to be
stripped away from human beings in our
country don't give two [ __ ]
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people
is not
liberty
it's in our intro folks
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people
is
not
liberty
liberty is what we strive for in our
democracy it has been
for hundreds of years
is it perfect no democracy is not
perfect
why should it be
should we strive for perfection
certainly
but not everyone is going to get what
they want out of a democracy
they're fighting
to oppress your rights
and we
us pro-democracy people
are fighting to preserve their liberty
and that's the greatest part about
democracy folks
that's the greatest part
is we get to die on the hill of liberty
where we defend not our right
to liberty
we defend everyone's right even their
right to liberty
that's what it's about
we've come a long way and we got a long
[ __ ] way to go
especially with these [ __ ] fascists
because they not only want to tear down
your liberty they want to tear down our
democracy they want to rip up and [ __ ]
on our constitution
they do not like democracy they have
decided that democracy affords everyone
they hate the liberty that they only
want to have
let me say it again the freedom to
oppress
the rights of other people is not
liberty
and if your goal
no matter what no matter what what
system that you're using in our
government
rather it be the legislative system
inside states or the federal legislative
system
rather you're using executive orders
governors
the president of the united states
are you using our supreme court
to take away the rights of other people
that
is not
liberty
i don't give a [ __ ] who they are
who they want to be
what color their skin is how tall they
are how skinny they are how fat they are
i don't give two shits what religion
they are
what gender they identify as who they
love i don't give a [ __ ]
if they're willing to take their liberty
so haphazardly
they will come
for yours
that's what fascists do
and they're not going to stop
they're not going to stop here they're
going to oh finally we overturn roe v
wade
okay now we can
go back underneath our rocks
crawl back underneath them and hide away
they're not gonna stop at roe v wade
this whole state's right [ __ ]
they're gonna give you that argument
they're gonna sling that [ __ ] at you all
day long
over and over and over and over again
stage right states rights
are the states rights more important
than human rights
do the states rights
are they way more important than human
rights are they
maybe that's a good question to ask one
of these anti-woman
trump pumping fools
because that's the cheering that's going
on folks
that's the cheering
and democrats all around the the social
media network
that is our internet
are playing right into their hands
trump got us the supreme court picks
and what do liberals do
what do the [ __ ] libs do
oh yeah it's his fault and her fault and
his fault and his fault and her fault
and his fault
they know how to divide us
they know how they're very [ __ ] good
at it they've done it for decades how do
you think we are where we are now
because they're good at dividing us
the fascists are damn good at convincing
the people who want to fight for
democracy that they're on opposite sides
there's only there's
there's only two sides right now folks
only two
only two there's only one goddamn line
and you're either you're either on one
side or the other you're either a
fascist and you want to tear down our
democracy or your pro-democracy and you
want to preserve it that's it
we're not federalist and anti-federalist
anymore get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] states right [ __ ] oh well the
state's rights the federal government's
rights blah blah blah blah blah get out
of here with that [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
we are not divided federalist
anti-federalist in this country anymore
that is all [ __ ]
and to say that the state has the right
to take away women's rights
to take away human rights get the [ __ ]
out of here we done did this [ __ ] with
slavery oh slavery's about states rights
civil war wasn't about slavery is about
states rights yeah states rights to
grant human beings to own other human
beings
that's what the civil war is about is
slavery
this fight here is not about [ __ ]
states rights i'm gonna show you a god
damn clip of what they're gonna do with
these states rights next
the state's rights to take women's vote
away from him the state's rights to kill
gay marriage the state's rights to kill
interracial marriage and i use the word
kill specifically
i'm using that word intentionally folks
they're ready
they're ready have you seen the videos
of these people saying when can we shoot
them at charlie kirk's events when can
we shoot them when can we start shooting
these people
have you seen the comments on twitter on
facebook on tick tock on instagram
we have a choice folks
and rather rather you participate and
engage with your feet in our democracy
or not you're choosing
you're choosing if you choose not to
engage if you choose to just cover your
eyes and say you know what
what's done is done
then you're choosing autocracy because
that's the choice
autocracy or democracy
and they want you to choose
i mean they want you to quit
they want you to give up
they want you to not fight
they want autocracy over democracy
that's what they want they're ready
they're willing to fight they're up on
the hill
they picked their hill to die on
we going to stand down in the valley and
try to coax them down in the valley to
have a
a real nice conversation with us
try to convince them that oh well your
ideas suck
we have so much better line item bills
we got all kinds of bills that we want
to pass we want to cancel student debt
stay down in the valley
stay down in the valley and try to
convince that the fascists to come down
and talk to you about canceling your
student debt
or we can all look at each other and go
you know what the only way to cancel
student debt
the only way to cancel student debt
is to absolutely destroy with our ballot
this scourge of fascism in our country
we
the people can do that
we can decide
yes we have our differences and yes we
may blame this person or that person or
this person but we ain't got time for
that kind of [ __ ]
we do not have time for that [ __ ]
and while they're standing around
trying to figure out who leaked this
decision as if that's what [ __ ]
matters
oh man
who leaked it forget about the liberty
being taken away from americans
and human beings human rights
forget about that forget about that we
want to know who leaked this information
and gave
and gave women in this country and
protesters in this country and
pro-democracy people in this country a
head start
that's what they're scared of
doubt me
so what are you going to do
you're going to stand around fighting
with each other
over which democrats going to cancel
student debt which democrats going to
not cancel student debt are you going to
do that are you going to go fight the
fascism
i want to cancel student debt do you
well we ain't gonna do that [ __ ] you
think these [ __ ] are gonna
cancel your student debt
they may cancel your right to [ __ ]
live
they're already doing it with women
right now as we speak
they want to cancel the right of women
to live
you don't even get to have a life-saving
medical procedure
there's a long history of the pro-life
movement in this country
long history
the ins and outs the bigotry
the way they used abortion as a cudgel
to divide us
to gain political power
to press their systematic racism
to press their anti-woman views on the
entire country
and we have fought back for decades
and fought back and fought back and
fought back
and now
now is not the time
to stop fighting
and using our weapon of the ballot
to win
this
battle because folks it's a battle
they're not going to stop they're not
going to quit they're not going to
it's not going to happen
and they're not going to stop at
overturning roe v wade oh they'll be
excited it'll be gross as [ __ ]
that they're going to be cheering that
americans had their liberties stripped
away from them
but they're not going to stop
not at the red states they'll come for
the blue states
they'll come for the 19th amendment mark
my words
they'll chip away and chip away and chip
away
they're not going to want women to vote
are you kidding me not at this point
goddamn women are going to try to vote
to codify roe v wade
if you're pro-democracy out there and
you are hearing my voice
it is time
it is time to band together
with anyone who will stand with the
pro-democracy people in this country and
who will fight to save
our democracy
which is the shining city on the hill of
western democracy
because ultimately
it's not just us that's at stake
all around the world
they're women
they're human beings human rights at
stake
and it's up to us
it may be up to us
to show them how important those human
rights are
here in this country
where we
say
our intention is life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
we have to prove it and today is the day
to start proving it
don't go anywhere we'll be right back